bonjour thierry renard bonjour moi aussi
au temps et bon vent à tous vos amis
terre nous a soumis un porte parole en
martinique en tout cas l'un des porte
parole du mouvement créé par jean luc
mélenchon en février de l'an dernier en
vue de sa candidature pour la
présidentielle française
jean luc mélenchon qui était en
martinique qui il ya quelques jours lors
de la sortie scolaire pour dire
plusieurs choses tout d'abord t-il
renard tout d'abord à ceux qui étaient
venus le voir il entendre soyez les
relais de l'avenir en commun le
programme qu'il entend mettre sur pied
pour être élu le discours de jean luc
mélenchon at il séduit nos compatriotes
alors tout d'abord monsieur viol dont
j'aimerais souhaiter les meilleurs voeux
à la population martiniquaise de santé
surtout dans cette période d'épidémie de
grippe ou le gouvernement actuel essaie
de faire qui est le moins de
remboursements et donc que les
martiniquais et que les français de
manière générale dépense encore plus
vous leur santé donc je leur souhaite de
tout coeur de rester en bonne santé et
mon deuxième veut si que il est beaucoup
de bonheur dans cette année 2010 est il
sera chargé en élection alors le
discours de mélenchon
le discours de mélenchon c'est un
fonctionnement tricot en martinique
comme vous avez pu le constater
la salle était trop étroite pour les
gens qui voulaient venir l'écouter et le
lieu était assez éloignée un samedi
après midi
c'est très rare d'avoir des conférences
à ces heures-là et nous avons été très
heureux du vif succès dans la paix va
lui la porte de discours sur une salle
prise d'assaut par quelques
sympathisants surtout que cela faisait
pas la plus grande de martinique
non ce n'était pas la plus grande de
martinique et ce n'était pas quelques
sympathisants qui l'ont prise d'assaut
mais vous savez le discours de jean luc
mélenchon fait écho partout dernièrement
j'ai regardé il y avait plus de 149
mille personnes qui le suivaient sur
youtube
c'est à dire que il a dépassé de loin
hillary clinton
c'est pas peu dire
donc c'est un disco qui fait écho parce
que aujourd'hui la cinquième république
est arrivé à son terme
on sait surtout ça son message oui mais
on est à bout de souffle
il est temps que le peuple reprenne la
main et dans le programme la venue en
commun nous avons trois grandes
priorités qui sont des urgences c'est à
dire une la 6ème république démocratique
qui est qui passe pour la 6ème
république
pensez aux gens des sarkozy ont tout
détruit selon vous vous savez très bien
que la vème république c était un
costume taillé par michel debré peau le
général de gaulle mais le costume s'est
avérée bien trop grand pour nous deux
derniers présidents sarkozy et le
sortant françois hollande
donc aujourd'hui il faut changer les
choses il faut que le peuple reprenne le
pouvoir et surtout le pouvoir qui a été
laissé aux mains de la finance la
démocratie participative
c'est très à la mode c'est très tendance
non non nous ne sommes pas d'un de la
démocratie participative pour dire que
c'est la démocratie participative la
6ème république va être fait à partir
d'une constituante c'est à dire que
c'est le peuple qui va l'écrire et ceux
qui écriront cette constitution ne
pourront pas participer aux premières
élections dont ils ne pourront pas les
crocs pour eux vous parlez d'un peuple
qui se détournent de plus en plus de la
chose politique justement parce que trop
déçu mais voilà il faut pas qu apparaît
par le quotidien aujourd'hui que ce soit
ici ou dans la france hexagonale
on veut nous faire croire qu'il y à une
simple bipolarisation de la vie
politique
tout ça pour passer de l'un à l'autre en
nous disant c'est blanc bonnet ou bonnet
blanc n'allez pas voter sentiers non
nous disons gens allaient voter même si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce que
nous disons nous les insoumis mais votez
blanc si une pluie de vote blanc qui
s'abat sur l'élection présidentielle au
moins là on prendra déjà en compte neuf
le vote blanc de notre le 10 mai
l'allemagne et le système de l'intérieur
mais il faut réformer le système de
l'intérieur et pour réformer le système
de lundi
or il faut prendre le pouvoir et nous
sommes là pour ça pour prendre le
pouvoir pour réformer
jean luc mélenchon a dit la première
chose qui fera et bien c'est mettre en
place sa 6ème république et donc
démissionner puisque de toutes les
façons il y aura plus de cinquième
république et il sera élu de la vème
république
donc s'il ya une sixième république qui
sera plus là alors jean luc mélenchon
lorsqu'il est venu en martinique
il a quand même proposé deux mesures
phares pour notre île la première
l'autonomie énergétique et la
souveraineté alimentaire de propositions
qui pourraient sur-le-champ crié en fait
sur le champ
sur les cinq six prochaines années de
nombreux emplois en martinique vous y
croyez ça parce qu'on en parle
cette énergie tic l'autonomie
alimentaire pourquoi on ne fabrique pas
nous-mêmes de poulet ou le déférer j'ai
écouté vos informations ce matin je ne
suis pas encore passer à la pompe cette
année mais j'ai l'impression que ça va
arriver mon tour de rein aujourd'hui
l'indépendance énergétique nous en avons
urgemment besoin et si c'est non
seulement problèmes énergétiques mais
c'est un problème écologique les
énergies fossiles
ce sont des énergies polluantes il faut
nous en débarrasser donc ça fait partie
des choses que nous devons mettre en
place urgemment et les 19 centimes ou
léon centimes qu'on a mis parce qu'il ya
un besoin d'argent mais l'argent il faut
le trouver autrement vous vous rendez
compte que si aujourd'hui on veut mettre
en place un véritable système pour faire
en sorte que les gens puissent se
déplacer correctement
c'est à dire refaire le réseau routier m
un transport à la hauteur de ce que les
martiniquais pourrait attendre lé
l'entrée de dormir notre sport donc le
tcsp en encore une chose d'assez de
qu'on leur mettra en place et pour
donner investi de l'argent n'ont donc
dit qu'on va pouvoir mettre quelque
chose qui va fonctionner ça voudra dire
que la ctm va tout faire pour diminuer
ses rentrées d'argent donc on est en
train de mettre en place un serpent qui
va se mordre la queue
donc ça ne va pas fonctionner si nous
changeons pas fondamentalement notre
mode de consommation et surtout notre
mode de consommation énergétique
j'avais que mélenchon lors de son
discours du 17 décembre l'institut du
sport a parlé de cette mère qui nous
entourent et qui pourrait très attristé
d'emploi tout simplement il faut dit
qu'ils pourraient crier tout de suite
des filières pour fabriquer ces engins
qui pourrait fournir de l'électricité à
partir de la mer il ya tout cela c'est
trop malheureusement ignoré par nos
concitoyens
vous avez l'énergie de la mer c'est
quelque chose qui est là c'est un c'est
un gaspillage parce qu'on n'utilise pas
nous avons à peu près 50 ans a fait plus
de trente ans qu'on attend ça nous un e
oui mais vous savez monsieur vergès
avait à la réunion fait une étude et
commencer un travail sur l'énergie de la
mer d'ailleurs qu'un apport à la réunion
qui est très bien là dessus ils ont fait
une centrale marine qui utilisent
justement l'énergie de la houle
ça alimente tout un quartier ça alimente
une piscine chauffantes et voyez c'est
pour quelque raison si c'est quelque
chose de propre
c'est de l'énergie propre créer des
filières de formation au siège de ce
parti mais qu'est ce qu'on vient de
vivre aujourd'hui il cessé de l'emploi
dont il s'agit et c'est de l'emploi dans
de l'énergie durable
le csr dont je faisais partie avait fait
un appeau là là dessus et on avait parlé
justement sur ces énergies mon moi même
j'avais participé à ce rapport
et justement je veux parler à cette
époque-là des soccer doc donc son de
boudin qu'on met dans l'eau et qui avec
le mouvement de la houle très simplement
de l'énergie de l'électricité mais vous
passez sur toute la côte atlantique
tous sont bien là mais qu'abattent donc
il ya toujours du coin à disposition et
je ne parle pas de d'autres systèmes
avec différence de température etc
l'indépendance l'autonomie plutôt
l'autonomie à
commentaire et là aussi ne comprend pas
que en martinique nous soyons aussi
dépendant des aides de l'export alors
vous voyez nous sommes dans une économie
encore de comptoir issus du colonialisme
c'est à dire que nous reproduisons pour
l'expo et on produit moins cher pour
exporter le maximum notre monoculture
quasiment c'est la banane alors si
aujourd'hui nous commençons à produire
proprement c'est à dire à faire que nos
agriculteurs produisent bio il faut
qu'il y ait un marché bio pour cela il
faut que premièrement les collectivités
donc les cantines fournissent du bio à
nos enfants de nos enfants ont besoin de
manger sainement
donc on va leur donner du bio à vous
allez me dire oui mais faut trouver
l'argent pour ça parce que c'est que
c'est pas évident mais si oui il y en a
plus avant il y en a plus mais c'est pas
pour tout le monde
je vous signale que la défiscalisation
c'est un milliard qui s'en va
défiscalisé pour des gens qui au lieu
d'acheter leur bateau en hexagone
viennent là c'est ici n'ont donné cet
argent directement à la production
locale à la production locale et nous
pourrons nous faire fonctionner effet
rançon que l'on produise bio on
développe le bio lorsque le marché
s'ouvrira les agricultures pourront
faire baisser les prix parce qu'ils
conduiront en plus quand non bien
entendu ça passe par la dépollution de
certaines terres et à partir de là plus
aux produits localement
- on a importé et moins on a importé
moins on aura exporté et plus on va
produire
serdar entrer dans un cercle vertueux
thierry renard comment relayer ce
message comme avec quels moyens
devraient le faire mais dans une
martinique on le rappelle éminemment
progressiste éminemment et les paons
dentiste mais écoutez la martinique est
progressivement politiquement progressis
indépendantiste avec des députés qui
vont siéger jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale
donc l'assemblée nationale française
oui donc nous sommes français je
rappelle aussi que les martiniquais
avaient voté pour le 74 à 20 pouces en
comptera 80
et puis pour la cote mal taillée que
nous a laissé monsieur sarkozy et qui
donne mal à la tête à tout le monde
c'est à dire l'article 73 dans un
costume du 74 que personne ne sait gérer
parce que c'est pas adapté pour et bien
oui parce que tout le monde et puis dans
dents dans cette mauvaise assemblée
telle qu'elle a été conçue
mais est-ce que deux ex réviseurs sexy
ne sais pas ce que voulaient les gens
mais on leur a donné ça et puis ils ont
pris part ce qu'ils voulaient un
changement mais on ne tranche pas pour
changer à tout prix il faut changer pour
aller vers le mieux je voulais revenir
sous contrat pour une restauration non
parce que secondes c'est quelque chose
d'important
comment se fait-il qu'on puisse bafouer
quand même une institution l'a traitée
de la sorte quand on le président lise
de passeurs de parole je n'ai jamais
entendu le député critique claude
bartolone de passeurs de parole je vous
ai bien aimé entendre ce même député
traité comme borderlands 2 passes rire
de parole
ça ça vous voyez si gênant si gênant et
c'est insultant pour tous les mardis sur
plus dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle oui mais non mais
justement et le temps imparti est finie
on aura l'occasion de reparler au cours
de ces présidentielle rappelle que vous
étiez danseurs crédit et que vous êtes
l'un des porte parole en martinique de
jean luc mélenchon est soumis de la
france
merci bonne journée merci au revoir
bonne journée